You imagine a time when Irish family meant a woman
having to give up her job
to stay at home
and mind the children and other domestic chores
while the husband or father went out to work.
Things are far from perfect now,
but times have changed.
Now doesn't that sound attractive?
The government wants to change
the constitution to reflect these changes
and we put two questions to voters in twin referendums
to take place on March the eighth.
Now, the Constitution doesn't
say that a woman's place is within the home,
but Article 41.2 does say that the stage
recognises that
by her life within the home,
woman gives to the stage a support
without which the common good cannot be achieved.
It also says that the state shall
endeavour to ensure that mothers shall not be obliged
by economic necessity
to engage in labour
to the neglect of their duties in the home.
Orders would be asked if they want to scrap this
and replace it with gender neutral language
with a new Article 42 b.
It would say that the stage recognises that the
provision of care by members of a family to one another
by reason of the bonds that exist between them,
gives to society a support without which
the common good cannot be achieved
and shall strive to support such provision.
The other question is on the meaning of family.
As things stand,
Article 41.1 says that the stage recognises the family
as A natural and primary fundamental group of society.
Voters will be asked if this should be changed
to insert after family,
whether founded on marriage
or other durable relationships.
But the exact meaning of durable relationship
is already causing some confusion. Troubles.
Truffles.
Yeah, truffles.
No, I did not.
I did not. Yeah.
Getting hungry
and. But that.
That issue has come up in some of the debate,
so we're very clear. Such a.
Such relationship is not covered within the concept of
your ability.
And it's not covered in the expanded concept
of the family that we are at that.
That we are.
Are. Are. Are seeking to protect.
The government says these votes
are merely about playing constitutional catch up.
So the Constitution reflects modern day values.
Bosh. The debate
is shaping up to be a bit more complicated than that.
You'll have your say on March the eighth.